[Music]
thank you
welcome to the data science hangout hope
everybody's having a great week I'm
Rachel I lead our Pro community at posit
I am based in Boston and I have some bad
allergies right now so if I sound
different that's why but the data
science hangout is our open space to
chat about data Science Leadership
questions you're facing and getting to
hear about what's going on in the world
of data across all different Industries
and it happens every Thursday at 12
Eastern Time
same time same place so if you're
watching this recording on YouTube later
the link to join us live next time will
be in the details below
at the Hangouts we are dedicated to
making this a welcoming space for
everybody so we love to hear from you no
matter your level of experience or area
of work or industry
it's also totally okay to just listen in
if you want you can also join in the
conversation jump in and ask questions
by raising your hand on Zoom
you could also put questions in the zoom
chat and always feel free to put a star
next to it if you want me to read that
question instead of calling on you to
jump in the conversation
and then third we also have a slider
link where you can ask questions
anonymously and thank you Hannah I see
you just shared that there
but with all of that thank you again for
joining us today I am so excited to be
joined by Natalia Andrew Chuck a
statistical data scientist in the our
Center of Excellence at Pfizer and
Natalia is a long time data science
hangout attendee too so so excited to
have you here we'd love to have you kick
us off with just introducing yourself
and sharing a little bit about your role
and also something you like to do
outside of work too
thank you yeah thank you Rachel and
thank you for having me you know it's a
it's very interesting when you join
Hangouts as the guest and then you um as
the person who's just like
you know coming as a guest and then you
come to listen to other people's Peak
it's just kind of a change of roles and
it's very exciting to me to be here
today
so yeah I'm Natalie Andrew Chuck I'm a
statistical data scientist at our center
of excellence and Pfizer I joined Pfizer
a year ago previously to that I worked
in cro for for like seven years it's a
contract research organization and I was
in a variety of roles and this was the
company where I actually transitioned
from more like a a project management
type of role to uh application
programmer and then
became a part of the data science team
there and now that I joined Pfizer a a
part of the SWAT team so there's our
Center of Excellence that has a our core
team
um and our SWAT team so the SWAT team
stands for I really like the um the
acronym it's the statistical workflows
and analytic tools and we primarily used
R uh for everything we do and we're
developing training we're providing
support for business lines on various
projects and projects can vary in scope
um for and support will provide the only
common denominator is like the all
written and are and we significant part
of our job is to provide the technical
expertise and also promote best
practices for the projects that people
already developing and also community
building is a big part as well
um and outside of my work last year I
discovered paddle boarding and I really
loved it and I live in North Carolina so
it's pretty hot in here now so I think
we can already start a season for pedal
boarding this year so I'm excited to do
that with my friends
nice I was just putting them out on my
list for things to do in Boston this
summer too paddle boarding in the
Charles
yeah well so excited to have you here
with us today and and I was I mean as we
wait for questions to come in from
everybody I thought it might be helpful
to learn a little bit more about the
SWAT team at Pfizer and how many people
are
on that team and kind of how you came
about creating it too
yeah so I wasn't the one who came up
with the idea I would I came later as
you know onboarded as a SWAT team member
and um Mike here on a call
um you can you can see him Smith MK uh
name so if if I say something wrong
please Mike feel free to jump in and
correct me so basically before I joined
um Pfizer there was an initiative to
streamline the process of you know bring
together the our users because when I
joined Pfizer I think it was about it
was shy to like 1 000 people on the
Microsoft teams Channel and Pfizer who
were either already knew are or learning
are and uh you know create um projects
in our and try to
um
learn themselves or find colleagues to
learn together and there were a lot of
projects who were going on which were
going on and are and the idea was to
develop the team to help to bring all
those people together to streamline the
training
um uh training part of it and also
provide support to business lines so how
to approach certain projects and um at
certain night questions also one piece
of it is
um I heard Mike was saying on the call
the other time they were guardians or
like production R tools so we have the
professional Suite of tools advisor
posit Suite
um workbench and uh package manager and
then you can also use the local version
of um R and people were a little bit
confused about that and we're still
providing that support and
um yeah so streamlining the learning
aspects of it as well
hey and somebody had just asked I think
maybe this was in the chat Andy's do you
want to jump in
foreign
my question was just if you also have
python users is there like a an r and a
python swap or is does everyone are
there Pfizer
yeah so we do uh have some pockets of
organization that use Python
um
I don't wanna uh I don't know the exact
numbers my impression from what I've
seen is maybe they're
um less users or they're less engaged in
building their own Community but the
um user channel that we have is like our
advisor user channels dedicated for
um also have we also providing a lot of
documentation we have like a Confluence
um part as well uh it's mostly dedicated
to our users
but anyone with python experience can
join and help us
I've been really impressed to see all
the different aspects of community
across the SWAT team as well and like
all these different
events and how you connect with people
across the company and I know that's
something that
um I guess happens for a lot of like a
lot of big companies they may have like
pockets of users in different areas but
it's hard to really like get everybody
together and start sharing that
knowledge across the team and I'd love
to just hear your feedback on how you've
been able to do that or some things that
have been helpful for you in getting
people together
yeah that's
that's a very good question and um
so we have the the SWAT team is like 100
dedicated
um consultancy group and then we have
the our core team and people on that
team
um they can be
pharmacians that programmers by
statisticians but they also help with
this initiative as well and then within
the core team we have multiple
initiatives which is like internal
Outreach external Outreach uh advances
in our communication education so we
have all those different streams that
are targeting different uh levels of
Engagement within R so for example
within let's say internal Outreach So
within internal Outreach we have the
hangout sessions uh similar to well very
similar to what we're doing right now
but within Pfizer and then we have the
book club and then we have the community
of practice events it's um every event
that happens every month where people
can come and colleagues can come and
present their various projects
um and it also varies in the expertise
level uh certain presentations kind of
very suitable for beginning lab
beginners level and then others are more
complex and advanced
um so targeting this um initi you know
approaching R and learning and bringing
people together from all the different
perspective kind of helps because even
if colleagues
can come to Hangouts this week maybe
they can attend commutative practice and
at the community of practice they would
hear about Hangouts and who's the guest
next time maybe they will have um time
to do that next time and then the book
club is also the initiative that is very
I think we have around
140 people now all around the world like
in Philippines and Japan and uh us and
Mexico so this was a big initiative as
well and then we have uh the external
Outreach where we track people who are
part of different external working
groups and we're trying to identify the
gaps and the representation so it's
um if I try to answer your questions
question kind of like in short it's uh
targeting uh from kind of different
um sources and different angles the
community aspect of it
thank you it's so cool to to hear that
you have the internal data science
Hangouts as well I believe you are the
first company to ever do that that I
know of
but it was giving me some ideas that
maybe I should put some documentation
together for like how to host your own
internal data science Hangout Too
yeah and I really want to like I cannot
acknowledge your help with it because
what happened is
um we reached out to you asking if you
could you know share your expertise your
knowledge your experience because coming
to the hangout and
um it's totally different uh piece from
facilitating it and I know it's probably
so much going on on the background uh to
actually putting this whole thing
together so you're very responsive when
I actually reached out and we set up the
meeting and asked a few questions
um
having the hangout I think within the
organization is very valuable because of
the added aspect of actually talking
about certain things within the
organization so for example if I come to
this hangout and we discuss uh certain
questions I get certain questions we
discuss certain topics sometimes I might
say well this is a great question but I
can't talk about it because the
information is appropriately like I
can't really share it which if you do
the hangout within your organization you
don't have to worry about that like all
people work kind of on the same project
or on different projects but you can
share the information together and this
is how certain problems get solved
faster or issues people are running into
and then it also brings people together
that wouldn't work together necessarily
um and
um I think this is very valuable uh part
of it
that's a great point to like bring
people together that wouldn't have
naturally been working on projects okay
so I see a ton of questions uh coming in
here and song you I see you had asked a
question in the chat about submissions
do you want to jump in
and I can read oh I've seen you've
unmuted
but the question was just does Pfizer
plan to use R for submissions
yeah this is
um I guess the question that every
company every Pharma company is asking
themselves
so I'll start I kind of take a step back
um I know there are a lot of great
initiatives happening in the Pharma
space and specifically
um within the r submission working group
within our Consortium and I think you
know we have a Eric here uh from that
group Americans and then uh my uh
co-worker Sam he's also part of
um one of the pilots or a couple of the
pilots and we're certainly as a company
probably are thinking about it I don't
have a good answer for you but I think
if I'm talking about my opinion is that
this is where Industries probably
probably moving towards
and this is definitely something that
companies gonna pilot and I think the
idea that the companies are actually
coming together and working together
open source within working groups kind
of we talks a lot about where the
industry is moving and that everybody
are interested in it and eventually this
might come to this point
thank you I'm going to jump over to one
of the slido questions and
see one one question on slido was do
these groups include bioconductor uses
genomic types or as a clinical group a
separate server group or oversight
um
I think about the working group or what
kind of group I think it's about like
the SWAT team and the center of
excellence if this is also including
like genomic uh type use cases and
people who use bio conductor as well
well if we're talking about and I'm
hoping I understand the question
correctly
um if we're talking about the projects
that we consult on
um there
you know there there's variety of
projects that people work on in
different like pockets of organization
and um sometimes we're
just solving the technical questions and
stuff and then if we're talking about
the SWAT team necessarily we're 100
percent are programmers that were hired
to help with those technical questions
and
um I hope we have will have different
backgrounds but I hope I
understand the question hope that helped
yeah and and for any anonymous questions
if anybody wants to add more context
feel free to put that into slido too but
Libby I see you had a great question in
the zoom chat do you want to jump in
here
sure
um and I'm really interested in Alan's
question as well hopefully that can be a
good follow-on
um I was wondering if
leadership has been supportive it sounds
like they have been or if there's been
any encouragement for people our users
you know not necessarily the SWAT team
people to spend a portion of their time
doing these community events like time
that's kind of taken away from them
doing their heads down work
um I know that having leadership support
to say hey spend 10 of your time or 20
start of your time doing that stuff
that's important is always helpful so I
was wondering how you guys had
approached talking with leadership and
getting kind of buy-in from them
yeah that's a very good question and I
think it's kind of an anticipated
question
um as well so I'm I consider myself a
lucky one because all the heavy lifting
about talking to leadership
um is done for me by my managers uh but
uh I I can't say that
from where I sit I see the leadership
support because
um even in the last semester there were
certain goals set towards having our
training and certain people a certain
parts of the organization uh were
encouraged to like start programming
we're encouraged to take the r training
and we developed the so-called mini
projects and hopefully we can
open those to the world one day it's
basically little projects that show you
how to work with the data create plots
manipulate data Wrangle all that sorts
of things create functions and then we
encourage all the programmers start
working on the mini projects so I think
that shows that
um the leadership is interested in
investing people colleagues learning are
and using them within
um
their job day-to-day work
I think Alan's question is a good
follow-up here too so Alan you want to
jump in yeah Libby and I were thinking
along similar lines I think the
questions really really relate and and
maybe Natalia you've already really
spoken to this um uh I was really
curious about how people come into the
role of doing this as something they're
really dedicated to versus as like a
side gig and you know technical
organizations I think have a really hard
time figuring out how to value that kind
of work versus you know productivity
measured in code and output and and
other kinds of things and so I'm just
curious like how many people are really
dedicated to maintaining this the like
really big Community as a as a focus
versus as a like a thing that they
dabble in and you know there's anything
that you can share about how you figure
out how to how to measure the success of
that for them
yeah that's a loaded question actually
and
um I think it's a grand continuation of
Libby's question too
um and in terms of I I just wanted to
add I think the idea that we have a SWAT
team a dedicated team that was hired
also shows and you know leadership
support because we do have those FTS and
in terms of how many people are in our
team right now
so the SWAT team is
six people
um yep
six people for right now and we're you
know this is the core team and uh
they're definitely
sorry I'm trying I'm trying to think so
that I don't say anything I'm not saying
and like how much I can share
um
so for starters for the projects that
are starting for bringing Community
together I think this is the perfect
size the way the organization gonna
build up on it it's kind of under the
discussion
um
how to show the return so basically
regarding the showing the return on
investment we are setting up certain
goals
um every semester that we are
moving towards and then we are trying to
show the leadership that it's worth it
and
um yeah it's it's kind of like a loaded
question for me right now maybe I'll get
back to that sorry it's like a lot of a
lot of things to process
no to later said really appreciate it
thanks
sure
I felt the same way Natalia when when
Mike was asking me questions when we had
our like no featured leader uh session
and then after I was like oh I wish I
said that to Mike
yeah and just so sorry Rachel I was
thinking maybe it would be easier to me
to um talk about the example because I
really want to come back to this like
return on investment question and stuff
and how do we measure the success so one
of the examples could be one um one
project we did last
um last year I think uh we developed
like the shiny framework it's basically
a process where the project team
um can specify and refine content within
the interactive environment of like
maybe shiny application and then
um capture certain settings and output
and in the production environment and
then this was the framework
and right now after we published it last
year certain teams kind of picked it up
and went with it and implemented within
their projects and now it helped not one
not two but maybe more teams to actually
um uh
facilitate their projects and
make the workflow more reproducible so
this is how I guess it works in this
setting right now where we can set up
certain tools or maybe moving forward
develop the packages that then can go
within the organization within Pfizer
and project teams can pick it up and
actually use it within their production
environments
thank you
um and Travis I see you had a question
in the the chat too do you want to jump
in next
sure
um understood that you all are thinking
about submissions as many are because no
one wants to be the first to face the
wrath of grumpy FDA reviewers expecting
SAS
um was what with that many with that
many active users
um involved in your community what are
there other projects or initiatives that
you're all using R4 that you're finding
useful
um I know for us we've found using our
markdown and things like that for
monitoring
um kind of safety reporting and even
metrics for like trial you know bi type
applications are y'all doing things like
that with r or are there other active
areas um that are not you know like
making sctm and atom data sets for FDA
um that's that's um ongoing
yeah so I know about a couple
initiatives so we have
um one of the teams within the
organization they're actually leading
the
um Admiral Admiral vaccine extension
package uh this is part of the farmers
initiative
and then
I'm not I'm not necessarily involved
into the like a study teams into study
teams so there might be like a harder
question for me to answer and this is
something that I can remember off top of
my head
um
so this is the one that like comes to
mind
uh Mike is in here so maybe if
maybe he has something
um you could think about but I don't
want to put him on the spot as well if
we're talking about the actual study
teams that's okay that's why I'm here
um so yes is the short answer Travis
that there's there's Pockets throughout
the organization organization using our
um so Global Supply is one
pharmaceutical sciences and you know the
not just the kind of GXP stuff so good
lab good manufacturing practice good
clinical practice but all kinds of
dashboards are being built for all kinds
of uses
um it's R has been used for quite a long
time in the clinical pharmacology and
pharmacometric space for predicting
PK concentrations and PK profiles for
for drugs and and different dosage
administrations
um those tend to be used kind of
internally so for internal teams to
address questions of what we do next or
for reviewing data as it comes in
um but you know those are not the things
that we submit to regulators
you know at this point but um
but yeah there's a at the bar and Pharma
conference two years ago I did a quick
look-see and there was over 1500 people
had downloaded our
so you know that's that's across the
whole organization and you know I can't
tell you what they're using it for
but
isn't it great to have your manager back
up
on the call like this
so I see there was a slido question
where I'm going to need some help with
acronyms sometimes here but the question
was Have you shared our programs for
reconciliation of reports delivered by
vendors which could be used for cros to
check EDC data with data provided by
external labs and I'm going to copy this
question into the chat that's a little
wordy too here we go
that's quite a complex question yeah I I
I'm not aware aware of any but I'm sure
there is
shared
um and we think that I can imagine
shared with whom as well
Have you shared our programs
yeah there is um
you know I know R is used within the
specimen tracking reconciliation I'm
sure it's it's probably used within
checking the EDC data
what is EDC data now
electronic data capture okay is this
some data I spoke I think yeah
yeah
um going back to the book club that you
talked about it's amazing to hear how
many people are in the book club all
over the world too and Caitlin I see you
had a question about it
yeah I did I was just kind of curious
what type of books are on the Book Club
list or what's currently on the list
right now
yeah so uh we just
started in terms of this is our kind of
first book book club and it's our four
day assigned second edition book club uh
we started starting from the very
beginning from the basis and uh we
thought that maybe this book is actually
can bring more people together because
um it's also a new addition and they
added a lot of stuff and it's very
helpful no matter what level you are
once you start reading it and I always
come back to that book
um and then I think if the book club
going to be successful which it's
um
we need we need to come up with the
metrics to measure the success as well
because as racial mentions like all
around the world and it's kind of hard
to
um keep up with the feedback as well and
gather the correct feedback I would say
um then I would move to maybe either
mastering shiny or Advanced R uh books
however Advanced are I think might be a
little bit too much for the next one
maybe mastering shining would be a good
one
yeah the r for data science is a classic
I love that one for sure
yeah
um and the book club
this is the like the first book club
initiative
um that I'm leading and we have a very
good feedback from certain um colleagues
and the idea that we had is that we
didn't want to add additional overheads
to people who joined book club so we
have multiple groups
um
since we have you know 140 or whatever
people uh about eight people in each
group we had to have group leads for the
for each group and
um
and then we didn't want to add like
extra complexity or extra preparation
time for those group leads so some of
the group leads they're very very new to
R but the idea of them just like going
there facilitating the discussion
learning asking questions was enough for
them to become a group lead because they
would have the support from maybe other
members of the the group that are more
proficient and are and the we have those
cases as well
I think that's a really interesting
Dynamic to have the newbies that are
being the group leads so I think that's
a really interesting take
and thank you I love seeing the
conversation happening in the chat as
well and I saw somebody had asked like
how many government agencies are now
using python or R and it's cool to see
everybody answering in the chat there
too
um but one of the questions on slido for
you Natalia is
do you find newer or younger employees
more likely to interface with you in the
SWAT team and is there some resistance
from older SAS programmers or is that
not much of an issue
so we definitely have the newer
employees reaching out to us we have
summer intern programs and uh we're when
we're on boarding interns the you know
our setup is kind of stat programming
and programming terms are set up as part
of the
uh kind of quote-unquote curriculum type
of deal and
um we
we are showing them where those mini
projects live and they go through many
projects so I think that's definitely
something that um new our users do when
they join the company or people who want
to learn r or fresh out of college
in terms of resistance
um
nobody really showed me in years
but I but if we're talking seriously I'm
sure
um there are situations where people
build their careers using SAS uh for
many many years and they build great
technical expertise and they mostly work
in SAS and maybe they
they need to know why
we need uh to start using our in certain
uh projects or maybe they don't want to
be part of those projects or they want
to have be like in their fast World
um but I think it's important for us to
um
communicate and create this community of
users uh why are as important than where
the industry is moving but we don't
we don't tell people to like stop using
SAS and start using our this is not
what's going on we just provide the
tools for them to start using our if
they're ready for it and that they have
this community where they can ask
questions and get support
thank you uh and Eric I see you have a
community focused question in the chat
so if you want to jump in here yeah
excellent um great to have you Natalia
it's great to always speak of you again
and certainly thank you for attending my
workshop last year that was that was
great fun but anyway
um
as as you many know I'm also passionate
about building Community internally
where I work and part of it is making
sure that not only knowing what is
capable of but R can do in the clinical
space and Innovative projects but trying
to have a diverse set of topics that
people can learn from and hence having
speakers be comfortable sharing their
work where whereas avoiding like the
same set of voices every time talking
about the similar things so what what
are efforts that your SWAT team is doing
to help bring in other people that maybe
weren't as comfortable about sharing
their work and getting them comfortable
to share and learn from others
Yeah so basically the question is how do
we diversify
um
the people who come in and speak about
what they do
okay yeah exactly
so I think some of the initiatives I
mentioned
um they kind of helpful with that so
within Hangout
can
um ask my co-workers since I'm pretty
new to the organization and this is a
huge organization so I can
um go to my managers or co-workers who
have been with the company for a longer
time and ask them about the names who do
you think should come to the next
hangout be uh what experiences we want
to share because uh we might have people
from stat programming coming people from
digital coming and they all have very
different experiences but they all use r
so the experience of using R within
digital would be totally different from
uh you know stat programming world and
um this helps to also diversify the
audience because certain people would
join thing hang out to support their
co-worker which happening to me right
now and thanks for all of you for
shopping
who are my co-workers
um and so this helps and then the
community of practice meetings that we
hold every
um every month they also
um help they're also helpful I think at
some point when we started establishing
[Music]
um these events we were kind of asking
certain people knowing that these
colleagues who would be eager to share
that they're in front lines of our
community building and then after that
when this initiative has started it
brought more people who actually
expressed interest into sharing or
certain presentations Inspire them to
actually go back to their team and say
Hey you know we we need to share
something or we're doing this great
thing we need to share with the world so
the community of practice when they uh
present we have two 20-minute
presentation talks and we try to
diversify more like beginner level and
more expert level or a more advanced
level talks and it also talks can also
be not only technical but around best
practices
um like mishaps stuff like this because
it's all internal you can share a lot of
stuff internally
yeah that's that nugget right there I
just want to emphasize again it's not
just the the speakers themselves but
it's the range of topics too one of the
biggest hurdles I've had is people
thinking that oh I have to have this
perfect to talk about it no no no no
sometimes my biggest mishaps end up
leading to an Innovative solution but
you don't get the full story just by
looking at the end product getting the
process there and being I hate to say
vulnerable but being comfortable with
sharing those stumbling blocks I'm
comfortable with it but definitely want
to help others feel comfortable with
that too
yeah this is this is actually a very
important point because it's
it's fine it's kind of a GitHub
mentality so you're committing your work
even if it's not perfect and then you're
pushing it when it's perfect so it's the
same you don't have to wait till the
last moment to maybe present the maybe
an external presentation but definitely
not
um internally and
um we had the presentations where people
were presenting the work that maybe
wasn't 100 finished and they were asking
for the feedback and this led to further
collaboration with other folks from
maybe other Pockets or the SWAT team uh
Pakistan organization or SWAT team
make a so you have your hand raised here
too yeah I just want to kind of um chime
in there to say that you know we've had
a a huge broad range as Natalia saying
and you know the the presentations I
love are from people that say things
like I just discovered R in the last
year and it's awesome and this is the
things that I find really nice to use
you know because that's kind of opening
the door and saying look I'm not an
expert but here's what I've found uh
which is fantastic but with the other
great thing is to showcase the variety
of uses of our throughout the
organization we had a hangout session
with someone from the uh it security
world you know our user for years and
years and years and yet still kind of
curious about new things like quarto and
dashboards and you know but he's dealing
with things like you know what was it
his his API using R had been hit
millions of times per day
and it's like oh that's not you know
that's next level compared to clinical
trial reporting right
yeah and we have uh we have certain
people who
kind of met so for example I'm leading
one of the groups in the book club and I
have pretty experienced programmers and
um my team as well and we're just
by reading the chapter
um something comes up like
um data formats or how to deal with
um a lot like a big amount of data and
stuff and we just start sharing the
packages the workflows and even certain
people who have been with working with
our for a while they might not use
certain tools that
people who maybe attended certain
sessions heard about certain tools then
the sharing process becomes inevitable
and leads to Greater collaboration as
well
so that just actually talking about that
internally too with with Rich who
created the GT package and he was
starting to think about like how he
could use pins and hadn't thought too
much about pin so I was sharing some
resources that I had seen and that we
shared in the hangout
and so it was cool just to see like how
you can speed up that process for
somebody by helping share resources with
them
um Javier I see I have your hand raised
here
oh thanks Rachel uh I'll lower my hand
here uh Natalia great talk so far uh
this has been excellent and I appreciate
my chat Mike chiming in also here and
there
um so I we just recently started at our
company these coffee chat Series where
we're paired with an individual in
another group
um like really not related at all
and I was recently sitting on a call
with a leader and you know just in
introducing ourselves we started talking
about R and
um he told me very seriously
oh yeah I know that's interesting uh we
don't use our be in our organization
because it's really a statistical
language and you know that's all it can
do versus python that can do x y and z
and like I was sort of taken aback like
oh my God how have you not heard about
all these resources we have at the
company for you know not just the posit
professional products but also like what
R can do in 2023
and it dawned on me that like
I don't I still struggle with
re like finding these pockets of
individuals or organizations in other
parts of the company
um to educate them on like modern R
usage so it's kind of an open-ended
question but do you have any tips on
like
how to sort of spread the word to these
types of people do you have
maybe a landing page or something or a
quarto page that your team has kind of
opened up for the entire company or or a
Confluence page I just I struggle with
how to get the word out in in that way
yeah we have um and this is a very good
question uh because I'm asking myself
that a lot maybe once a month
um so we have a lot of resources we we
do have a Confluence page uh again the
team's Channel we do have the associated
like Microsoft teams website that
associated with it where you can come
and there are tons of links that are
cross-linked between the Confluence and
this
um website and then the teams
um for certain announcements we're
tagging the whole team's channel so that
people receive the notification there
are multiple channels within the whole
Channel there are multiple extremes
questions and answers general or in
Pharma so
um a lot of resources there
one one thing that I think is a little
bit hard is that sometimes you can work
hard on actually creating those
resources and this is what we're doing
we created so much documentation since
last year on various different topics so
the rule of thumb if somebody's coming
to us with a question and we answer this
question we write a Confluence article
about it especially if it may be helpful
for other colleagues within the
organization but I think the hard part
is also marketing uh because the
resources can be all there available at
any time no passwords required but
people just kind of maybe choose to
ignore it not because they want to it's
because there's so many other things
happening they're working on the
projects the deadlines are approaching
um I even had one colleague who asked me
how to
um opt out of uh notifications he's like
you're saying too many how can I opt out
and it's kind of a situation where then
the same person can later come and ask
why he or she didn't uh see the
announcement about the meeting that they
were interested in
um so I think there is a very thin
balance of where you should notify
people about upcoming events but maybe
don't overdo it because then it becomes
a white noise and they just start
ignoring all the notification and
everything
what we chose to do is that
during some of the events like for
example in the community of practice
events we would make an announcement
about Hangouts and hangouts we can make
an announcement about book club or
community of practice so we're kind of
cross-linking all the events and making
announcements here and there because a
person can join one meeting but then
skip another one but constantly
reminding uh people about certain things
that are going on are very helpful and
then
um else we also discovered that maybe
having
um easy access to certain resources for
example if you have a team's Channel
make sure you pin certain messages or
certain links and teams so that it takes
people one click not two but one click
to get to the resources they need and
eventually
um I think with a lot of training this
will become a pattern and people will
start sharing share the share sharing
the knowledge with other colleagues and
they will start sharing those links with
each other
thank you
yeah thank you so much I am getting
slightly distracted by this amazing chat
that's happening at the same time as
well and all those conversations
I'll send it to you too so that you can
see it Mike I see see your hands raised
yeah sorry I'm just gonna add on to that
that after the user Community meetings
we
we kind of saved the slide decks and you
know that becomes a showcase for what R
can do
um so that's one way of kind of having
that you know internal
um place for people to see what art can
be used for
um the nice thing again because that's
internal you can be as specific as you
like and you can you know talk about
real kind of detail of the project you
were working on and you know where to
find resources where to even find the
code to make things happen that maybe
you can't share externally
um the other nice part of it is the um
the uh
sorry there was the sharing in in the
community side
um
about kind of influencing it upwards to
let people know what R can be used for
um I think it's you need a handful of
cases where you can demonstrate someone
being superhumanly uh efficient
and that will get Management's you know
attention really quick it's like you
went from data to final result and how
long
um you know that will get on our
attention like no Biz business so you
know that's where things like markdown
and shiny and things like that are
gateway drugs for R because managers
will just look at that and go that's
amazing how do you even think about
doing that
I've been trying to frame our like our
customer stories in that way too or like
conference socks I see to try and put it
into like two or three sentences and one
that's coming to mind right now is Tiger
Tang who was on here and he said how he
saved 12 000 hours
with r and just like putting that number
out there front to front and center to
get people's attention
um but I love all this conversation here
I feel like we could go for two hours on
on all of this
um Stephanie I see you had a great
question in the chat quite a bit earlier
here and just wanted to
pull you in here if you're still on
hello hi Natalia this talk has already
been so interesting thank you for oh you
hear me
I can okay
thanks for joining us am I delayed on my
internet or is it on this side oh I
think it might be a little bit delayed
but not too much
okay okay good or maybe not at all
well um I asked my question back when
you were talking about your book club
um thinking about people
working their way through our for data
science and they get really excited
about using our
um they use Mt cars to make a GG plot
and think this is great but then they
get back to their desk to do their
day-to-day job and sometimes people have
a hard time actually putting it all
together to say make a tlf for their
regular
everyday work so I was wondering if you
had any thoughts about this and how
you're kind of trying to bridge that Gap
with your team
this is um this is a great question
thank you Stephanie
um yeah and this is one of the questions
we also asked ourselves and I think this
is where those mini projects came in
because the mini projects are actually
focused on the data like
um sdtm or atom data that we're using I
don't quite remember but this is exactly
what we're doing there so basically
those
um concepts of plotting data wrangling
data creating functions
um
applied to something that they would do
in their regular job creating different
listings and tables and specific plots
that they would create
but I guess there's also this component
of Bridging the breaching the Gap where
you attended the book club and maybe you
haven't heard about the meeting project
so there's a lot of like advertising
going on in that space as well and then
since book club is joined by so many
different people from different parts of
organizations they may even do different
things like we have one person in my
book club who is part of the real world
data
team and then the other person who's a
part of statistical programming team so
they pretty much face different
challenges
as well but I think they're also
supported by some of them also supported
by their own teams and given tasks
within their own teams as well
thank you and Nicholas IAC had a
question as well on some of the
collaborative efforts in Pharma
sure yeah I was just interested if you
had any thoughts on yeah collaborative
efforts if they're actually helpful what
you might think about something like the
Pharma verse and also you know are there
any discussions as stuff like Pfizer
potentially joining
yeah thank you uh Nick for this question
and I also want to um let people know I
know Nick from RTP our user group that
we're creating together we had our first
meeting this week
um we didn't like the attendance was a
little bit lower than I would have
wanted but it's also was just the first
meeting so if you're in the RTP North
Carolina triangular Research Park area
go to your Meetup page and search for
our user group and join us next time
um yeah so pharmac
um we are actually as a SWAT team we
started looking at the farmiverse
packages uh to see what each of them is
doing and where we can help and
contribute this is an ongoing discussion
and uh some of us and I know that
well when I'm thinking about Farmers I
know it's kind of like a subset of
packages
um and when I'm thinking about all
packages that do
um uh clinical research or connected to
clinical issues is way bigger than I
guess Pharma verse but
um we do have some people contributing
to the
um packages so one of them I want to
mention Sam parmar I think he's on a
call so he already started contributing
to one of the farmerverse packages
logarex and um
I think he's doing some good progress
there and I think Nick was also involved
in that package as well so
um package that I already mentioned the
Admiral Vixen extension package were
contributing to that one and I know
there's so many great packages that we
potentially can contribute to but we
first need to kind of assess when we're
dealing with and then create a plan on
how to move forward because there are a
lot of Open Source packages we also
looked into uh teal I don't think it's a
part of the Pharma verse package but it
was used in the
um our submissions working group so
um
yeah there's there's a lot of um there's
a lot of packages to look at and figure
out the plan on how to implement them
internally and if there is a need
thank you
I'm seeing a lot of love for this this
Meetup Group too and we shared it we
shared the link in the chat if other
people want to join that or know people
in the area too yay
congrats on on getting that started too
I see that there's a slido question on
where does your team get funding and is
there a reporting line in the
organization are you part of clinical r
d
yes uh we're part of
um
so okay so the reason it's I think our
group gets funded from
um like different places so semini sit
in one part of the organization and Mike
is actually in UK he's in another part
of organization and then we have two
members in our team who are uh part of
Pfizer India and they're supporting that
team as well so I think this is uh
what's unique about our team it's not
like we're uh Team sitting under what
one part of organization but we're just
kind of spread out a little bit
um
okay this is really hard to go through
the questions we didn't get to yet in
four minutes so I'm gonna try and uh
and go through and see what I maybe have
missed but if there was something that's
really pressing for anybody feel free to
just raise your hand here on Zoom too
okay
um one of the other anonymous questions
was are there members of your
organization's QA team who participate
with the SWAT group
yes so
um going back to this one example I gave
about the shiny framework we actually
were working with the uh QA people to
make sure it aligns with the standards
we have for uh quality assurance
um so yeah
keep in touch with them
okay a question I wanted to ask you
because I'm scrolling to find the other
questions and I
not sure what I missed but something I
wanted to ask you is if somebody in the
group today was thinking about starting
their own internal data science hangout
like what's something that you've
learned from that process
yeah so that's that's a good question
um it was a little bit overwhelming to
think about it and how to start it
um but then
um
one thing you would need is the list of
people who at least like 10 or 15 from
the start and then you would what I
would do I just like give my example I
would send I would identify the person
first I created the calendar of events I
would think would make sense we do
Hangouts every other weeks
so I specifically put the dates I would
invite people to and then I will
um send them the invitation asking to be
a part of hangout I actually started
Hangouts with um Mike you know and uh
Douglas Robinson he's also part of our
core team who are moving initiative
forward so I thought it's a great start
to start from the people who are
actually like interested in also doing
the Hangouts um there will be first easy
to Hangouts especially maybe if you know
colleagues or you work with certain
colleagues that you already have a
report established with so do that and
then invite people and then I set up the
Microsoft uh form that I would send out
asking about you know regular
information occupation bio maybe certain
questions they want me to ask and then
they would fill out the form and I also
asked them to provide their headshot I
think it makes the hangout out
Invitational but more colorful
and then what I do what I still do now
is that I schedule a 30-minute call with
each
um guest like the week prior or
something to go over any questions that
person might have if they never attended
they hang out or it you know something
that can come up and then it actually
helps me to know more about what they're
doing especially if this is the first
time I'm actually having one-on-one with
this colleague because sometimes I don't
you know I'm pretty new to company as
well so we would chat a little bit about
their interests what interests them and
are and stuff and then yeah then we have
the hangout session and then I'll try to
have at least three people booked in
advance
that's awesome I I love the point about
um kind of meeting as a smaller group
first so that when you got to the first
hangout that you also had some people
there to kind of help you with the
conversation and then get people talking
too
well thank you so much Natalia for
joining us today and it's been a
pleasure learning about how you're
running these Hangouts internally and
it's given me a lot of ideas of things
we could share too to help others do
that so thank you again for joining if
people do want to get in touch with you
is the best way LinkedIn or what you
prefer yeah I think LinkedIn Twitter
um will both work awesome well thank you
all so much have a great rest of the day
and hope to see you back next Thursday
thank you so much thank you for having
me and for all the questions